alors la cour de justice de la
république est elle appropriée dans ce
cas de figure faut-il une cour spéciale
pour juger les ministres ou les anciens
ministres ou plutôt une justice de droit
commun pour des hommes aux parcours peu
commun c'est l'objet de notre face à
face ce soir et pour en débattre
nous sommes en direct avec fabrice di
vizio avocat du collectif c 19 bonsoir
fabrice di vizio vous représentez de
nombreux soignants qui ont déposé plein
de précisément contre le gouvernement
pour la gestion de cette crise du
coronavirus pour débattre avec vous
philippe gosselin la liaison
manifestement skype c'est un peu
compliqué ce soir ça nous contraint être
en direct par téléphone seulement avec
philippe gosselin député l ère de la
manche qui est juge titulaire justement
la cour de justice de la république vous
avez été élu à cette fonction novembre
2017 par l'assemblée nationale bonsoir
philippe gosselin merci d'être en direct
avec hambourg nord est désolé pour cette
liaison entre calpe et qui marchait très
bien à 19h15 quand on a fait l'été vous
n'êtes pas coupable du réseau français
je crains philippe gosselin on va
essayer de les battre
oui oui c'est vrai on aurait bien aimé
vous aussi vous vous voir à l'écran face
à fabrice division mais n'hésitez pas en
tout cas à débattre avec lui ont
néanmoins alors cette mini sept
ministres jugés en en 27 ans d'existence
plus d'équipements que deux
condamnations
alors cette cour spéciale on s'est
parfois controversés on dénonce souvent
une une justice à deux vitesses françois
hollande voulait lier la supprimer
lorsqu'il était président finalement il
ne l'a pas fait très décriée vous en
avez conscience justement on imagine un
philippe gosselin oui tout à fait bon
moi je ne mourrai pas pour la cour de
justice je vous dis tout de suite
maintenant et qu'on peut être prendre le
temps de réfléchir un peu à ceux qui
réellement cette institution et et son
intérêt on rappellera quand même que
ça commence à dater mais c'est l'époque
révolutionnaire jusqu'en 1993 est quand
même intéressant où les ministres avait
une immunité complète ou
été jugés uniquement par le parlement
donc la cour de justice de la république
en 93 quand elle a été instituée au
moment de la faire vivre sans contaminer
c'était réellement un plus qui
permettait qui permet de juger les
ministres pour des crimes ou des délits
commis dans l'exercice de leurs
fonctions donc il ya quelques petites
dizaines d'années c'était un vrai plus
maintenant le système est loin d'être
parfait j'en conviens mais pour voir par
quoi on le remplace parce que je crois
que sans vouloir défendre à tout prix
les mini trous un exécutif en
particulier les fonctions ministérielles
ne sont pas tout à fait le droit commun
pas tout à fait équivalent d'un délit ou
d'un crime entre guillemets classique me
semble-t-il
fabrice di vizio d'accord avec le
diagnostic justement de philippe
boesmans est pas comparable à un crime
de droit commun
monsieur gosselin se trompent pardonnez
moi monsieur gosselin a contre lui
le droit ce qui est d'exception c'est la
justice la juridiction pas le délit les
ministres sont jugés pour des délits de
droit commun pour des délits relevant du
code pénal comme vous et moi
mais dans une des conditions compatibles
avec l'exercice de leur mission les
assises de la prérogative par une
justice d'exception
le débat n'est pas de savoir s'il faut
remettre en cause les conditions du
droit commun la con direct le débat est
de savoir s'il faut que ces délits
ordinaires soit jugé par une juridiction
extraordinaire c'est un autre débat et 2
fait ce que dit monsieur gosselin enfin
juste sur le constat c'est à dire que
c'est un progrès cette colo chi doit
public faux pas faut pas bouder son
plaisir non plus vient il ya
effectivement un vrai progrès on a mis
du temps à faire émerger il a émergé il
est pas parfait ce système et il doit
être réformé
ça me paraît évident on met notamment
réforme qui doit absolument et
mise aujourd'hui à l'ordre du jour c'est
le fait qu' il ne faut pas qu'il y ait
de parlementaires dans cette cour il n'y
a aucune raison que la fonction
judiciaire que l'autorité judiciaire qui
est distincte du pouvoir législatif soit
venu soit quelque part envahi par celui
ci soit envahie par le législateur le
législateur juge ça n'existe pas c'est
une réminiscence finalement de cette
haute cour où on a fait le chemin à
moitié ayons l'audace de venir consacrer
une juridiction d'exception pourquoi pas
mais avec des magistrats de l'ordre
judiciaire de bout en bout dont c'est le
métier dont c'est la fonction
constitutionnel fait beau ça sur ce
diagnostic de réformes ou les
législateurs n'ont finalement rien à
faire dans cette cour qu'est ce que vous
répondez
j'ai quelques principes sur lesquels ou
pour lesquelles je serai prêt à à
combattre mais je ne mourrai pas je les
lis pour la cour de l'uci de la
république et qui a bien bien des
faiblesses sans doute est en effet la
première c'est d'être une juridiction
d'exception et la le coup et est
évidemment imparable maintenant il ne
faudrait pas laisser croire que c'est
une juridiction politiques qui gèrent
des affaires entre soi
on a certes des parlementaires six
députés et six sénateurs qui font partie
de la formation du jugement
mais en réalité cette formation de
jugement elle n'intervient
éventuellement en bout de chaîne
on a d'abord une commission
d'instruction avec trois juges
titulaires qui sont des des hauts
magistrats de la cour de cassation
on a ensuite en deuxième étage de la
fusée si l'on peut dire
la commission des requêtes avec des
magistrats du siège de la cour de
cassation deux conseillers d'état de
conseiller maître à la cour des comptes
et là il n'est pas du tout du tout
question à ce stade d'avoir une approche
deux parlementaires ou une approche
politique donc
ne laissons pas penser à celle des ceux
qui nous écoutent que les parlementaires
font la pluie et le beau temps dans
cette juridiction je crois que ça serait
totalement impropre et ailleurs dans les
plaintes qui ont été déposées
officiellement et clairement à aucun
moment les parlementaires ne sont dans
la boucle ne sont informés de quoi que
ce soit ce n'est que lorsque
éventuellement la formation de jugement
hora wa à se réunir que les
parlementaires sont dans la boucle donc
voilà ce n'est pas totalement
l'exception à l'exception et il est bon
de le rappeler aussi alors vous pouvez
vous faire réagir fifa braisé vision
vous donnera là bas la parole je vois
vous avez envie de réagir aux propos de
philippe gaussent non mais écoutez ses
déclarations récentes de patrick
maisonneuve un patrick maisonneuve c'est
l'ex avocate christine lagarde l'ancien
ministre de la finance vous en souvenez
devant la crj au moment de l'arbitrage
en 2008 de l' affaire tapie crédit
lyonnais
interrogé il ya quelques jours sur la
multiplication des plaintes contre le
gouvernement la question est ce qu'on
recherche un coupable ou la justice
écoutez sa réponse
c'est une soif de coupables on a déjà
vécu dans les années 1990 au moment de
l' affaire du sang contaminé
je retrouve cette situation où c'est la
recherche à tout prix de responsabilité
pénale est individuelle et je crois que
l'on confond absolument tout c'est la
recherche d'un coupable pénale à tout
prix et je regrette d'ailleurs qu'un
certain nombre d'avocats se prête à ces
initiatives d'engager des procédures
pénales sur un sujet qui ne l'est pas
enfin brice bijot vous êtes en quelque
sorte visé puisque vous êtes en se fiant
c'est justement de ces plantes qu'est ce
que vous répondez
à cet homme patrick maisonneuve qui vous
diront vous recherchez absolument un
coupable
non seulement je suis en soutien mais je
suis le premier à l'avoir fait les
premières plaintes c'est nous qui les
avons faites
je suis le premier chronologiquement
d'en déposer ses pelotes et à patrick de
maisons de jeu répond ceci
n'avez vous pas l'impression cher
confrère d'être un peu désavoué
aujourd'hui votre propos à l'heure où le
parquet lui considère qu'il ya matière
pénale le parquet vient ouvrir des
enquêtes chapeau préliminaire
pourriez-vous encore soutenir que ça
n'est pas pénal quand effectivement à
madame lagarde est la recherche de
coupables
vous avez défendu madame lagarde est ce
qu effectivement cette recherche de
coupables et bien avait avait propos sur
cette question ce que nous cherchons
dans la justice pénale ça n'est jamais
la recherche de coûts passés recherche
de la vérité
et j'ajoute que là où le propose de
mettre les honneurs traduit quand même
quelque chose d'assez caractéristiques
de cette crise c'est que nous sommes
dans une espèce d'auberge espagnole où
tout le monde fait tout sauf qu'ils
devraient faire
moi je fais du droit moi j'ai le droit
de saisir la cour de droit public je le
fais je ne cherche pas de coupable c'est
faux c'est à dire j'ai un respect
profond pour la présomption d'innocence
qui fait que vous ne m'avez jamais
entendu dire que qui que ce soit et
coupables pourraient potentiellement
l'être et je même dit je vais aller plus
loin puisque j'ai même dit que je me
réjouirais si effectivement au terme de
l'instruction il devait s'avérer que
finalement il n'y ait pas de délit pénal
parce que ce serait heureux pour le
fonctionnement de la démocratie donc il
faut pas compter sur moi et venir me
faire faire un procès politique dans
cette affaire celui qui fait de la
politique c'est celui qui tient ses
copeaux et qu'effectivement sait
pertinemment pourtant que le droit nous
permet de le faire et que l'avocat
finalement ne nous y trompons pas et
auxiliaires de justice
mais j'ajoute un point rapide si oui je
réagis ce que dit monsieur gosselin
d'auteur sur le fait que quand même
c'est une juridiction d'apparatchiks
soyons d'accord
la cour de justice de la république est
une juridiction d'apparatchiks et en
témoignent les condamnations qu'elle a
prononcé les poignées condamnations
qu'elle a prononcées sous sans commune
mesure avec celle qui pour les mêmes
délits
regardez dans
la ministre de la justice avec la
violation du secret professionnel et
monsieur thierry solère les
condamnations prononcées tous les soirs
conventionnelle est dérisoire nous dans
notre profession d avocat jeté en prison
pour ça donc on vienne pas me dire que
cette justice est autre chose que cette
élection
autre chose qui ne les tue un
apparatchik vous n'êtes pas tellement
excessivement cher maître queux tas
devrait pratiquement envie de mourir
pour la cour de justice je voulais dire
moi je ne cherche pas à dépendre à tout
prix un système qui était en 93 une
amélioration par rapport à l'inexistence
encore une fois il faut bien avoir en
tête qui se faisait à cette époque et
depuis la révolution péter ou une
impunité totale
une immunité totale ou un jugement par
le parlement lui-même
aujourd'hui la cour de justice existe on
fait avec et je n'oublie pas qu'il ya eu
des projets de réforme ceci étant la
révision constitutionnelle de 2018 pour
le moment patiner et je pense qu'elle ne
verra pas le jour
donc la révision et la suppression de la
cour de justice de la république n'est
plus vraiment d'actualité
mais dans tous les cas il n'était pas
question est beaucoup du risque
d'ailleurs d'accord pour dire que c'est
plutôt bien il n'était pas question de
donner à des tribunaux classiques les
compétences en matière de jugement de
ministres en exercice et il était prévu
dans le projet d'avoir la cour d'appel
de paris qui te résisterait compétence
sera prêt après une question
d'incrimination qualification juridique
des faits est en effet au droit pénal et
je ne peux pas vous dire autre chose au
droit de poursuivre son oeuvre et si
culpabilité il y a si la commission
d'instruction transmet la commission des
requêtes bien la paire suivra son cours
et je peux vous dire que je n'ai pas
d'états d'âme et nous serons en notre
âme et conscience comme tous les
magistrats
notre travail de moment venu ça me
paraît bien la moindre des choses dans
un état de droit
merci fabrice division et merci à vous
également philippe gosselin en espérant
la prochaine fois qu'on pourra vous voir
apparaître également dans cet écran pour
débattre avec vous merci
d'avoir été en direct sur rt france dans